-New York governor Andrew Cuom
recently allowed weddings
in the state to resume with up
to 150 guests, as long as --
-Wow! Weddings, huh?
You've got to be kidding me.
-Oh, I'm sorry.
This is one of my writers,
Dina Gusovsky.
Dina, are you not
on board with this plan?
Are you worried it might
lead to a COVID spike?
-Oh, yeah. Sure.
-Frustrated with Governor Cuom
and his handling
of the pandemic?
-Oh, I am very frustrated.
This is the worst time
to have a wedding.
-Yeah, I mean, I think
we can all agree with that
-How am I supposed to
have a wedding
when I don't even have a groom
-Oh, boy.
-Seth, I thought I had years
to get married.
You're telling me I need to find
a single Jewish guy
to marry now?
This is the real
public-health crisis.
-Dina, I don't think this mean
you have to get married.
But, you know, I'm sure
there are plenty of
nice guys who would.
-Please, Seth.
Do you have any idea how har
it is to date during a pandemic?
I mean, I haven't been touched
since I heard Amanda Gorma
read that poem at
the inauguration.
-Dina, I know it must be hard,
but people are still datin
during COVID, right?
-Oh, great.
Another COVID-safe date.
If I wanted to be in
a relationship where
we had to sit 6 feet apart
I'd get married in Connecticut
-Look, Dina, I don't want
to criticize you,
but is it possible
your standards are too high?
-Didn't realize you and
my mother had been chatting.
But maybe I should
widen my search.
I mean, I guess not
every gentleman
can be the Second Gentleman.
-Really, Dina?
You're still pining over
Doug Emhoff?
-Still? Even more now.
Look at him.
Oh, man.
That guy really gets my
Jewish space lasers beaming.
Seth, I can't help it
if he sets my forest on fire
One glance at him,
and I got to clear some brush.
-Uh...
Well, Dina, I'm sorry to say
but, as you know,
as we've discussed here
on the show multiple times
Doug Emhoff is already married
to Vice President Kamala Harris.
-Oh, trust me -- I know he
mixes with the shiksas.
But with a body like
Doug Emhoff's,
I'm willing to look
the other way.
-Here's the thing
I can't get past.
I understand that Doug Emhof
has a lot of the qualities
you're looking for in a husband,
but the fact you find him
to be such a physical specimen
I just don't see it.
-Well, I guess you
better tell my dreams,
because they did not
get the memo.
I don't want to get too graphic,
but every morning,
I have to wring out my sheet
like a dishrag over the bathtub.
-Dina!
That was almost
incomprehensibly graphic.
-Hey, Seth,
I'm playing to the crew.
I know what they like.
[ Laughter ]
Look, if Cuomo wants to allo
150-person weddings in New York,
I guess that's fine.
-Oh, yeah? Why's that?
-Well, if these weddings
lead to another spike,
maybe I'll meet a nice
Jewish doctor in the ICU.
-There you go.
Dina Gusovsky, everybody.